this was always going to be a different
Winter Olympics one where nearly all the
snow is artificial where there are no
tickets on sale for spectators and one
which has been boycotted by Western
governments
it's also one in the middle of a
covid-19 surge in China districts across
Beijing are conducting Mass testing and
locking down neighborhoods
and there have been lockdowns across the
country
officials have been typically zealous in
their pursuit of what's called a dynamic
zero covered policy sometimes fighting
covet with literal fire
or sending dozens of young children to
quarantine
as a result the Olympics are being held
in the closed loop system keeping
athletes and anyone else coming for the
games and potentially bringing covid
isolated from the rest of the country
this was one of the athletes Villages
before the loop closed uh
and so it's Fortress Olympia
officials have even told Beijing
residents not to help Olympic Vehicles
involved in traffic accidents for fear
of breaking the loop it's a pretty
formidable barrier what they've done is
create a city within a city actually a
country within a country because over
that barrier there's effectively
international territory carved out of
the heart of Beijing
an ordinary members of the public cannot
buy tickets to events only those
selected by the Chinese Communist Party
can attend despite all that locals are
still excited and proud that their city
will be the first to host a summer and
winter Olympics foreign
if not a panicked one authorities will
be relieved if they can focus on the
sport instead of covid Tom Cheshire Sky
News Beijing